congratulations are in order for bindi
irwin
i'm excited the 22 year old wildlife
conservationist
just became a proud mom giving birth to
her first child a baby girl
with husband former professional
wakeboarder chandler powell
it's nice because every day is an
adventure the dancing with the stars
alum took to instagram to share her
pregnancy news back in august
with the caption chandler and i are
proud to announce that we're expecting
it's an honor to share this special
moment in our lives with you
it's been so special i mean it's kind of
in this wonderful moment after another
the couple got engaged in 2019. you're
kind of like my soulmate
they tied the knot in a small private
wedding at the australia zoo in march
2020. having the wedding here at
australia zoo that's
that's what means the most with my
family bindi shared with et
the importance of honoring her late
father crocodile hunter steve irwin by
keeping her last
name i think that for me personally
you know after after dad passed away it
was really important for me to
feel close to him and having his last
name means so much to me
i mean i know taylor has become an hour
now yeah totally
it's a it's a part of me but i think i
think it's it's really special though
everyone has their own
customers the nice thing is is that it's
20 20 now so
anything works and chandler gives all
the credit to the crocodile hunter for
bringing them together
in a way he brought us together because
when i came to australia
after watching his documentaries so the
biggest thing i would like to say to him
is just
thank you for inspiring my passion in
life and
also bringing me and ben together
because if it weren't for him i don't
know how he would have met bindi and
chandler kept fans in the know with
regular instagram updates about their
journey to parenthood
quote we couldn't wait to share the news
as this beautiful little being has
become the most
important part of our lives chandler
followed up the same pick on his
instagram with the caption
becoming a dad is the highlight of my
life i cannot wait to embark on this new
adventure and life chapter with my
gorgeous
wife i'm really grateful to have found
you i don't think i could be with anyone
else in the world
to be honest congratulations bindi and
chandler on your new
baby wildlife warrior we consider
ourselves
very very lucky to be healthy and safe
and with the ones that we love
in a beautiful part of the world